لم يكن هناك سلام ولا صمت في جزر الباهاموت
عشية عيد الميلاد الأرثوذكسي
، ولم يتحقق وقف إطلاق النار الروسي أحادي الجانب
أبدًا ، ولم تصمت المدافع
في أحد ملاجئ المدينة التي
يتجمع فيها السكان حول طاولة مصنوعة من الطعام
ورموز عطلة
تاتيانا التي يحاول متطوعها  لرفع
الروح المعنوية ، نتمنى لكم صحة جيدة
ورخاء وسلام ، وكل خير
تخبرهم أنها تعلم أنه من المهم أن تضع
وجهًا شجاعًا
على الرغم من هطول الأمطار
والثلوج في الخارج ، فأنا أبتسم تقول تيتيانا أتمنى
للناس عيد ميلاد سعيد أحاول إظهاره
إنها تأتي من روحي لقد
تمكنت من رسم الابتسامة
للطفل الوحيد في الملجأ فلاديمير البالغ من العمر تسع سنوات
ورغبته في هذا اليوم
أريد أن تنتهي هذه الحرب
وأن يعود جميع أصدقائي ، يقول للكبار
إن  الهدية تحت هذه الشجرة هي الكهرباء
لشحن الهواتف المحمولة وجهاز توجيه لاسلكي
متصل بوصلة قمر صناعي
تتيح اتصالاً ضعيفًا
لأحبائهم لطمأنتهم ولكن يمكنهم
أنهم لا يزالون  لا تعيش بشكل
جيد وهنا يوجد دفء في مدينة حيث
تم تعطيل المرافق العامة منذ أشهر ،
ولكن من الصعب أن تشعر بروح العطلة
كما يقول أندريه إنه يوم محدد للغاية
مع تقدم اليوم يبدأ الثلج في
التساقط ويستمر
عشاء ليلة عيد الميلاد هو أمر خافت
في  هذا الطابق السفلي هو منزل في الوقت الحالي لعدد قليل
من الأطباء الذين ما زالوا في باهاموت ،
باركنا الله بالقوة والصبر
والتحمل هو نخب الدكتورة إيلينا مولتشانوفا
ولكن هنا القوة لها حدودها
أشعر بالألم كما تقول لأنني لا أستطيع أن أكون
مع عائلتي أستطيع  أجلس على نفس
الطاولة مع والدتي وابنتي
صباح عيد الميلاد ولم يتوقف
القصف
منذ شهور ، حاولت القوات الروسية
الاستيلاء على هذه المدينة لكنها فشلت حتى الآن
ولكن في هذه العملية وفقًا
لمسؤول محلي أكثر من 60 في المائة
تم تدمير البقموت
في كنيسة جميع القديسين الكهنة يحملون
قداس في أمان نسبي من
الشموع توفر الضوء والدفء الوحيد
في هذا أحلك الأوقات
بن ويتمان سي إن إن.